i look forward to the day one of these
vigilante stings
goes wrong and these so-called pedophile
hunters winds up
dead wishing death on so i don't even
wish death on pedophiles i just want him
to be held accountable that's a really
really extreme comment
from clearly a potato that just sits
behind a keyboard
this guy needs his search history
looking at quicktime
[Music]
hi i'm mike from dark light i'm a
pedophile hunter
i appeared on a video a couple of months
ago i'm back today to
reply to some of those comments let's do
this
sentences for pedophiles should be the
same as murder sentences it literally
it's literally
murdering children's childhoods
i've been a kid that has gone through
abuse i've been a kid that has witnessed
the after effects of what abuse does to
you i mean i've got bipolar i've got
complex
ptsd it's something that will never go
away so yeah
i definitely think the sentencing needs
to be increased
it's disgusting and it just shouldn't it
shouldn't exist in society
it shouldn't you people
are i have been physically attacked
stocked
and harassed by pedophile hunters
claiming i am a convicted pedophile
when i'm not it's unfortunate that you
have been
um physically attacked stopped and
harassed
however that wasn't me
it's you know it's really really
important to me morally
um that i get it right just so you know
we're not implicating anyone
that is innocent and that's never
happened we've never got the wrong
person
we have a 100 rate of of getting it
right
my father was a paedophile was never
even charged
told hospital cops they did nothing
that's the way it was in the early 60s
he's dead now thank god
i am so so sorry that you had to endure
what you were to endure as a kid
no child should ever have to go through
that but
you were failed by the system the
important message to you directly is to
know that you did nothing wrong
it was forced upon you you had no choice
in the matter
and most importantly you survived
you got through it like strong strong
person thank you
this is a really important question and
how many of those friends requests are
from middle eastern men i wonder
two percent i'd say two percent were
from middle eastern
98 white british males
just saying don't don't look at
stereotypes they're real types of bs
these vigilante should all be charged
with crimes
i look forward to the day one of these
vigilante stings
goes wrong and these so-called pedophile
hunters winds up
dead wishing death on so i don't even
wish death on pedophiles i just want him
to be held accountable that's a really
really extreme comment
from clearly a potato that just sits
behind a keyboard
this guy needs his search history
looking at quicktime
ah what he does is entrapment is it not
no it's not we never send the first
message ever
we're contacted by the person at the
point that they contact us
they're informed that it's a child
they're speaking to with an
age and it's then down to them
to decide whether or not they want to
have the conversation it's their moral
compass not mine
it's not entrapment otherwise i'd be the
one going to prison and not them
when they set up a decoy profile what
pictures are they using for the profile
that's a really good question actually
now what the decline pictures are are
historic pictures of
people that are now adults and we then
have them
sign an authority forum that authorizes
us to use historic pictures of them as
children
um to catch the bad guys let's see him
go after the elites but he won't do that
says who people have this person
presumption that
pedophile has only concentrate on the
lower end of the scale
if i can find someone that's at the top
of the ladder that's abusing kids while
them people are protected i'll do
everything in my power to take them down
you've only got a look at what's
happening in hollywood the elites have
got a massive problem because the
world's waking up the power of one
that's beautiful
if i can stop one person just one person
with this from becoming another version
of me
and and having to live the same kind of
life that i have then
you know that that's the power of one
i've seen
and encountered some of the most
grueling things you could ever imagine
some of the conversations that i've seen
have kept me up at night
but if i can stop one kid
from encountering that and
stop that happening then then that's
that's what we have to do in it
what do you think should happen to these
people like is there a way to
rehabilitate them i don't think there's
any rehabilitation for him because i've
seen so many repeat offenders
i've caught so many repeat offenders
i've caught people who have historically
raped and abused children one guy in
particular
we caught him while he was in a bail
hostel and he was meant to be managed by
his
you know his mapper officer having no
devices yet he had two phones and an
ipad
thank you to this money story is amazing
i always wondered why most of the time
the pedophiles themselves were abused as
kids after they know what it feels like
to have that done to them
you would think they would never want to
do that to somebody double edged to
comment that
my story is far from amazing it's good
what i've turned it into
and i'm incredibly proud of what i've
turned it into but
it's it's a difficult pill to swallow i
genuinely don't believe that pedophiles
all pedophiles or the the vast majority
of pedophiles
have been abused themselves for me i
could think of
three or four different predators that
i've stood in front of that were abused
as kids themselves
that's a very very small percentage
adult in that statement is true
[Laughter]
he's the batman of 2020. both of them
were affected by crimes
um when they were a kid and now they've
vowed to stop it a lot of people kind of
come up with these superhero
comments and whatever else but i'm just
a dad
that went through some pretty heavy
stuff when i was a kid i think
personally the rest of the world is
crazy for not doing what we're doing
everybody is accountable for children
even if you've not got kids
here i am three three years later with
a lot of convictions a lot of
reoffenders caught
and a lot of real children protected i
never imagined when i started out three
years ago that i'd be having
conversations with people in south
africa
people in australia or people in canada
we're now on the back of the last video
working with different organizations and
different umbrellas
to try and raise awareness in schools
and with parents and with
young people if you're a parent and
you're seeing this video
what i really want you to do is go and
check your child's device
children are at risk pedophiles are
online
it's not going anywhere but the
prevention
starts at home and you do find anything
speak to the police
please speak to the police because my
inbox is full
[Music]
the following day she went and gave a
statement and secured five counts of
rape on him
and on the fourth of june just connie
was jailed for eight years
that's a real person that's a real
12 year old who's had to live through
those times
and then just you know just because i
put a picture on a facebook page
for her to come forward and disclose one
that she's been raped and abused by him
but then to go
own it and follow it through he had no
no option but to plead guilty